one really nice thing about making
biscuits is they are really simple
pretty much you should have everything
in your pantry hi i'm angie and today
i'm going to show you how to make the
flakiest biscuit i'm using biscuit flour
which is predominantly used in the south
you can't really find it sometimes
outside of there so you can just use all
purpose flour so when you get to the
step of adding your butter you want to
make sure that it's very very cold so it
doesn't melt out before you bake them if
you do not have buttermilk you can make
buttermilk take regular whole milk or
even low-fat milk and you can add lemon
juice or white vinegar you want to add
about a half a teaspoon per half cup the
buttermilk adds that nice richness and
flavor so i grew up in north carolina i
definitely grew up eating a hole like
those kids we mainly had them for
breakfast then when i was living my city
life and i didn't have access to
biscuits that i was used to having
that's why i had to learn how to make
them
i like to roll them out fold it over
once fold it over again and then cut
from there and i find that it adds a lot
of layers
when you bake them you definitely want
to have a nice rise if you've done
everything correctly they should double
in size and then you definitely want to
have a nice golden brown on top you
don't want them to get too dark because
once they get too dark they probably are
also going to be a little dry
i'm from the south so i would say with
butter and jelly you can make a sandwich
you can definitely put a piece of fried
chicken which i think is probably the
ultimate way to have it and maybe some
honey
[Music]
let's taste that color
oh yes
[Music]
you